We Begin this hour with an incredible
story of Courage for Black History Month
we're sharing the stories of three girls
who helped change history 62 years ago
at six years old they desegregated their
New Orleans School the same morning as
Ruby Bridges integrated a different
school just blocks away but their story
has often gone Untold Jamie wax he met
with the pioneers who are nicknamed the
McDonough three after the school they
integrated they talked about the heroism
and why they returned to their school to
make history once again
it was integration day today for the
first grades of two New Orleans
elementary schools it was a short walk
but perhaps one of the most historic
alongside U.S Marshals three little
girls stepping foot into McDonough 19
Elementary in New Orleans to desegregate
schools in the state for the very first
time creating National impact local
police and large numbers were on hand to
see that integration took place without
trouble on the morning of November 14
1960 six-year-olds Leona Tate Gail atien
and Tessie Prevost were met by the Roars
of protesters
what was your sense as a child walking
past all of that did you know it was
directed to you with the way they were
hollering and making noises I thought if
they could have got to me they would
have killed me they were angry with me
and I didn't know why
six years old I didn't understand why
they were acting like that
my daddy told me in the car he said look
straight ahead
take my hand and I'm here
and
I wasn't afraid for some reason I just
wasn't afraid I felt protected with my
daddy and then one by one every single
student left except for the three of you
every single student every single but
the teachers stayed yeah they had
received a telegram that morning telling
them if they didn't report to school
they would be
no violence but plenty of vocal abuse
for the rest of the year Tate ET tiananm
Prevost remained the only students in
the entire School Ruth now Bridges has
to go to school but the media's
attention was on first grader Ruby
Bridges who desegregated William France
Elementary School in the same city on
the same day somehow the world knows
Ruby Bridges you were sort of Forgotten
in the in the mix did you feel that way
oh yeah oh yeah you know because just
knowing what we went through you know
and for people not to remember that was
hurtful
they hold no resentment toward Bridges
they forged on but will never forget the
abuse they faced in the other integrated
schools they attended throughout
childhood and at first year I I was on
nerve medicine for a while
as a child as a child at six years old
yes
had Sims I got hit in the summer with a
baseball bat and the teachers didn't do
anything about it the principal nobody
was like it didn't happen
you got beat up in the classroom to spit
on us
spitting our food
in a way there's no possible
ability anyone has to express or or
discuss what you three have shared as a
shared experience I mean that's a very
special bond
assistance
brought them back to the school
years later this time with a new Mission
the Leona Tate foundation for change
recently purchased the school
transforming the building that's been
vacant since hurricane Katrina into an
educational space that opened just a few
months ago it's called the tep Center a
nod to their three initials we are
sitting here
in the school that the three of you came
to as six-year-olds tell me about
reclaiming this space for what it is now
this summer is to educate those that
didn't know about the integration and
the desegregation of public schools and
if you feel like you're a part of that
this is the place you come to try to
solve that problem oh wow this this is
the classroom this is the classroom
visitors can step foot into the original
classroom the girls were confined to in
1960 the only room they were allowed to
sit in this class was full of students
when we got here
but in a matter of few minutes they were
all gone
upstairs the top two floors of the
building have been converted to
apartments for seniors Like Richard
Johnson the first resident to move in
when I come to them doors them glass
doors and I'm inside this is like heaven
this is spot only this is a special spot
this is special do you feel a sense of
the history of this song trust me I do
it's just like a caterpillar turn into
the cool and it didn't turn into the
butterfly
that's what happened it's beautiful
this caterpillar of a building has only
grown with time what started as the
center of pain for three little girls
has turned into one of Hope for the
three women today
[Applause]
in fact November 14th has officially
been declared New Orleans four day in
the city recognizing the heroism of all
four Trailblazers whose short walk led
to Lasting change I'll ask each of you
would you do it again if you had to do
it again yes I worked
yes all three
it made it better it opened up doors
opportunities for other people you know
so somebody had to make the sacrifice
and I guess it was the three of us
children
the chosen ones yes
many people are hoping to get that date
November 14th nationally recognized as
New Orleans four day and I have to say
guys on a personal note my own first
grader goes to an incredibly diverse
Public School in New Orleans more
diverse than the one she would go to in
New York City think about that for a
minute thanks to the sacrifices of the
New Orleans for and their families just
unbelievable wow Jamie I have never
heard of these women before never heard
this story thank you so much just for
educating all of us about that and it's
heartbreaking to look at those little
girls I love the little black patent
leather shoes and the little white
ruffle socks everybody I know had one of
those The Bravery that it took at that
time and they don't even know why it was
so vitriolic just looking at the hatred
of the people's faces taunting at them
screaming at them and their little girls
not knowing why are you treating us this
way what a story yeah it's a power you
know it's it's an incredible reflection
on our society to watch that Through The
Eyes of an innocent child right exactly
that's why these stories need to be told
yeah thank you Jamie really lovely piece
well done thank you very much all of
them all those women